[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBBAIAH VENKATA: Hi.
Good afternoon.
I'm Subbaiah Venkata,
senior manager at Google.
I'm happy to be
here with you today.
Let's get started.
We are going to talk
about seamlessly
migrating your networks
and workloads into GCP.
So what is the agenda?
Next slide.
So we have three
speakers here today.
I'm Subbaiah.
I'm going to talk about
why and how you should
migrate your networks into GCP.
Then Ines is going to talk about
specific use cases and service
model.
Then the concluding
remarks and hybrid
use cases, a talk by Amit.
So why you should
migrate your workloads
into Google Compute Engine?
What is so special about it?
What are the advantages
of Google Compute Engine?
If there is anything you
want to take out today,
this is the slide
you should remember.
This is the one slide
we captured everything.
Google networks are great.
The performance is amazing.
We can get 14 Gbps throughput
single zone VM to VM.
Similarly, we can give 100
microseconds, round trip
latency, VM to VM, single zone.
This is very amazing.
We'll talk about how we're
able to actually achieve
such high throughput on low
latency in the next slide,
coming to how fast
you can actually
bring up VMs in Google Cloud.
You can bring up, like, one VM,
two VM, up to 1,000 plus VMs.
Thousands of VMs you can
bring in a couple of minutes.
In average three
to five minutes,
you can have 1,000
VMs up and running.
Third, your network performance.
You can have-- we implemented
a seamless hit list of grids
offered in raw structure.
That includes kernels
or hypervisors,
software different
stack, so many components
without having any kind
of network performance
degradation for the VMs.
We were able to do that behind
the scenes migration of VMs,
upgrade the stack, and
move the VMs back in.
Second, global network.
It is not just a
GCLB global VIP.
It's much more than that.
From the beginning, we
designed and architected
the networking stack with
a global view in mind.
That means you can create a
virtual network in any zone,
multiple zones, across regions.
Thousands of VMs,
you can scatter them
in all the different zones.
You can have high
throughput and high latency.
The last one is network
functions as service.
We have spent last year,
entire GCP, 320 plus features
and functions.
Networking alone, we have
tens of features and functions
we have implemented in one year.
Thanks to our great design
and architecture of software
different networking
stack, we are
able to channel
features so fast,
now we have all the necessary
and sufficient functions
for you to migrate your
workloads or networks
into Google Cloud.
Those include networks,
virtual networks, subnetworks,
HTTP load balancing, HTTPS load
balancing, TCP load balancing,
UDB load balancing, Cloud DNS,
Cloud CDN, Cloud VPN, Cloud
Router, so on and so forth.
We'll talk about all the
different categories next.
Let's step back.
I talked about getting
a 14 Gbps of throughput
and 100 microseconds of latency.
This is not possible in a
day or a week or even years.
If you look at the
Google's history,
Google has spent decade
or so plus of innovation,
perseverance, a lot
of money, resources
are spent on meticulously
designing the networks.
Google networks are amazing.
This is a good example
where you can see that.
We published papers
in seminal [INAUDIBLE]
and reputed journals.
In 2013, we published a
paper, "Before VAN Traffic
Engineering."
This is a groundbreaking
paper and first of its kind
to do software-defined
networking at a global scale
of a VAN network.
Similarly, we published a
paper in 2015 [INAUDIBLE]
about how we architected our
software-defining clusters.
We started with Firehose
clusters in 2005
and Watchtower clusters in
2008, 2012 Saturn clusters,
finally, in Jupiter clusters.
All of these are available
published in a paper called
"Jupiter Rising."
These Jupiter clusters
are fantastic latency,
very high throughput
than anyone in the world.
Then in 2014, we published
a blog post about Andromeda.
Andromeda stack powers all
of Google's Compute Engine
networking stack.
With this SD and
architecture for Andromeda,
it's possible for
us to implement
features, any kinds of features,
not just external features,
internal features, including
isolation, encryption,
encapsulation.
All of these
features are possible
because of our
design of Andromeda.
To recap, you can see that
we have software-defined VAN.
We have software-defined
clusters.
Finally, we have
software-defined
cloud virtual networks.
Because of that, it's
possible to see and get
very high throughput
and very low latency.
We are not going to stop there.
Over the years, you are going
to see amazing results because
of these investments.
So let's step back and look at
what are the different cloud
networking tools and
functions available?
We categorized them,
after listening to you,
into four different categories.
The fundamental first building
block is our virtual networks.
As we discussed, you can
create virtual networks,
virtual machines,
containers, across the globe
crossing different
regions in a single API.
Then last year, we released
more granular subnetworks.
You can group a set of IP
addresses, VMs, or containers
into a subgranular group
by zone or by region.
We'll get to how the
subnetwork's IP addressing
and naming works
in the next slide.
Coming to the second
point, what about control?
People ask, we would like to
see the control and security.
Control is very important.
How can, as an organization,
trust certain individual
get access to manipulate
the resources.
Certain people
actually get to change,
certain people get to
only view the resources.
We have given couple of
networking IAM functionalities
called network admin role,
network user role, security
admin role, and
instance admin role
for IAM, which is
in beta right now.
And then once you have
the control set up,
how about the firewalls?
I would like to ensure the
security of my networks, which
VM is supposed to talk to which
other VM, I need the control.
Then we have a
firewall solution.
You can get up 200
firewalls rules
with very granular scale
or very microscopic scale.
You can configure them.
Based on reputation, you can
get even more firewall rules.
These firewall rules are both
at L3 level and L4 level.
And you can actually apply
them at the name, target name,
or IP range level.
And global scale.
For web-serving applications,
we deliver all necessary load
balancing features, like SSL
load balancing, TCP, UDP load
balancing, HTTP load balancing,
HTTPS load balancing, DNS,
and Cloud CDN.
These tools are
sufficient for you
to click on few
buttons in the UI
and actually deploy your
web-serving applications
as the previous
talks talked about.
The final one is
hybrid offerings.
If you wanted to partially
move your application to Google
Cloud, you want
to extend out, you
want to scale out your
on-premise sites into Google
Cloud, we have three
different products, Cloud VPN,
have [INAUDIBLE] IPv6 VPNs,
which does 1.5 Gbps per tunnel.
We'll talk about that later.
And then we have Cloud
Router functionality,
where you can BGP functionality
to dynamically learn
the topologies and
learn about the changes
between on-premise search
and Google Compute Engine.
The final one we have
is Cloud Interconnect.
You can connect
data through to us
or through a carrier exchange.
This entire set
of features is now
sufficient, necessary for you
to migrate to Google Cloud.
We'll see how we use
all of these features
to migrate your workloads.
But let's step back and
see an example architecture
before we migrate a
couple of use cases,
how does all these things
fit together visually?
For example, you have a
start of an organization,
I would like to see how
all of this fit together.
Think that on the
left-hand side you
have Google global network,
go physical network
in different regions, and
each region has zones.
In other side, you have
an organization set up
where you have given
certain privileges
to certain individuals.
Then the network
admin comes along.
In the UI, he just
creates with a few button
clicks a virtual network.
And then he divides
the virtual networks
into subnetworks, another
few button clicks.
It's available.
You can create up to
hundreds of subnetworks
in a particular region.
And then security
admin comes along
with a different IAM role.
Hey, I'm a security admin.
I would like to secure
your subnetworks and VMs
in this fashion.
For example, say that only
one subnetwork get access
to the private or
public internet.
The rest of the
subnetworks are not
supposed to access the internet.
All of this is possible through
security firewall rules.
And then comes along
service accounts.
We have enabled service
accounts so that you
can access Google cloud storage
APIs, other Google services,
with a specific--
that means specific,
only VMs and applications
can use our Google services.
You can do that through
service accounts.
This is also another
form of security.
Then network admin comes
along, creates Cloud DNS,
and starts serving
through load balancing.
That you have seen before.
And then you want to see
that, oh, no, actually, I
have couple of
on-premise data centers.
I would like to connect them.
Then in one of the subnetworks
in one of the regions,
you bring up cloud VPN and
cloud order functionality
and start connecting to optimize
data centers very securely
through [INAUDIBLE] tunnels.
These are all the
building blocks.
Some of them are,
for example, missing,
but you can visualize
this Cloud Interconnect
and how this works.
This is how the networking model
we architecture and design.
This is a global scale one.
Let's look at how is
the IP addressing?
IP addressing and
naming are very
fundamental for networking.
You had to get this right.
So we have spent a lot of amount
of time talking to customers,
talking to you, getting
the input to see, actually,
how can we provide a
seamless migration for you?
The moment you go
into the Cloud console
and create an account for
Google, create the project,
you get a default network.
You don't have to
create any network.
We call it default network
is pre-created for you.
Inside the default network, we
create auto-mode subnetworks.
We have two different modes
of subnetworks we create.
But auto-mode, we pre-create
one subnetwork in every region.
These are non-overlapping,
non-contiguous different
ranges.
We pick the addressing
range for you.
You don't have to know what
is the addressing for you.
Then you come along and
say, I'm a power user.
I don't want you to create
actually auto-mode subnetworks.
I want to create many
such subnetworks.
For example, you may say
that each of my service,
I wanted a subnetwork.
Maybe Google Play services,
You can do that.
You can create up of hundreds
of subnetworks in a network.
You can see in one
of the regions,
we have two subnetworks.
There are more advantages
to custom or subnetworks.
You can bring in your
own private address base
into Google Cloud.
We have no restrictions.
You can bring in the entire
RFC1918 space for you.
RFC1918 space consists of
three different networks,
10/8, 11716/12, 190 to 116/16.
All of these things
available for you to use.
Then we have a flexible
allocation model.
You don't have to create
contiguous subnetworks.
You can create very random
subnetworks from the IP space.
As much as hundreds of
subnetworks you can create.
With [? replication, ?]
actually,
you can increase
the subnetworks too.
And these are expandable.
That's very key important.
For example, you created a
subnetwork range, /20, /24,
let's say.
The number of VMs increased
because of your load increased.
With the click of a button,
you can change subnetworks.
You can increase
it from /24 to /20.
You can go all the way
up to /9 if you want.
Now, from now onwards, we're
going to, step by step,
increase the complexity
of migrations.
Let's look at
traditional data centers.
How traditional data centers
are visualized and then
how the cloud is visualized,
one by one, step by step.
In the traditional DC, you can
see complex networking setup.
You have top of rack switches.
You have cloud networks for
high cross-sectional bandwidth
from server to server.
You have to design with
[INAUDIBLE] subscription,
different, different
buffer ratios or whatnot.
And then you have
an aggregation layer
where you combine
multiple such clusters
and export services
out of the internet.
Then you have a DMZ perimeter
to come create all the security
rules.
You buy some boxes
from different vendors.
You buy different boxes
for the load balancers.
You attach the load balancers,
some security [INAUDIBLE]
there.
Some of them are L2.
Some of them are L3.
I think you have to
translate the VLANs into L3.
There are so many
things you are doing
to the traditional
on-premise one.
In cloud, everything is gone.
You have a UI in front of you.
Everything is consistent.
Everything is done for
you behind scenes, even
the REST APIs.
Click on few buttons, all of
these things will be migrated.
So you don't have to think about
no more [? cloud ?] networks.
No more this top
of rack switches.
Everything is perceived from
the perspective of your services
and virtual machines.
All you have to think about
is, I have a set of VMs,
think that these VMs are
all connected together.
They're all connected
to the full mesh.
You get more than 10 Gbps of
VM to VM throughput and 100
microseconds of latency.
Why do you care about
the networks anymore?
You don't need to worry
about cloud networks.
You just create a
bunch of subnetworks,
put the VMs in the subnetworks,
[INAUDIBLE] have web servers.
I created a subnetwork
for web servers.
I created a VMs for application
servers through button clicks.
And then I bought some storage,
maybe Google Cloud Storage,
and I have a big
query attached to it.
Another button--
click of some buttons,
you created a load balancer.
Single VIP.
Done.
So no more thinking
in the perspective
of complex networking
terminology anymore.
Everything is through REST APIs.
Behind the scenes,
Google takes care
of all the migration for you.
From now, Ines is going to talk
about service model and very
specific use cases,
the batch use cases,
web server
application use cases.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
INES ENVID: Hello, everyone.
It is really great
to be here today.
It is such exciting
times for us.
And as you heard Subbaiah say,
we've been really, really busy.
So hopefully you're
going to be as excited
as we are on what we are
delivering to you in terms
of capabilities.
And I want to start by
recapping on what Subbaiah said,
because it's really important
as the foundation of what we do.
So there's three things
that he pick up on.
Those are network
performance, first,
and all the work that has been
done in Google infrastructure
to get where we are today,
which powers everything we do
and it is really in our DNA.
We talk about the global scope.
Google is a global network.
And everything we do,
it is in that spirit.
We provide private
connectivity globally,
and then we give
you the flexibility
to then choose whether you
want the granularity to build
regionally and have the
flexibility of communication
within the scopes that you need.
Then the third thing is
everything as a service.
Everything meaning networking
functions in this case.
So that we are really providing
the level of structures
that you need, so you
can map your services
and we'll take care
of the rest for you.
So having said that, what
I want to talk to you about
is, how do you use those
capabilities for what you need
for bringing your
services to the cloud
and mapping them flexibly?
The first way I find
useful thinking about this
is about the services.
What the service needs.
And that is going
to somehow determine
what are the type of
capabilities that you'll
need in our Google Cloud.
And you're in good hands.
We can incorporate a
lot of different models.
You can have services that
are latency sensitive.
So they need to
restart locally and you
need to be close to the
user for low latency.
You can have services that
require failure isolation.
And you need to be cautious
about your failure domains
and how you build
geographically as well,
and which scopes your service
is to provide that redundancy.
Replication.
May want to have
global replication
for services like databases.
And this security and privacy
very important who has
permissions to do what and
how services can communicate
with each other.
So if you think about
what the services need,
I think you can then
have this model of what
you need in the network.
So services, we provide
templates, service identities
so that you can build your
services with policies,
with recipes that you can
replicate, you can automate,
and you can scale.
With the requirements
of the grouping,
it comes the network virtual--
the virtual network grouping
and the subnetworks grouping.
Do you need global
communication?
You can bring a
network global scope
and build the granularity of
what you need with subnetworks,
configuring your CIDR
grouping so that they
can communicate as you need.
So for data locality, you
can build your subnetworks
regionally and then you
can communicate globally
if you need things
like data replication
or a service that is consuming
from publishers that are
distributed all over the world.
And of course, then all
this maps into geography.
So what is the failure
domains that you need?
What is the availability
that you need?
And then you can come
up with your strategy
on how to map those into
the different zones, regions
that we provide.
And then on top of all this,
it comes the organization.
And again, it's who has
the control to do what?
And this is very
important so that there
is autonomy for the services
to operate and set up policies.
But at the same time,
there is a framework
for network
administrator, for SecOps
to be setting the rules that
are going to-- that need
to be conform with
their infrastructure.
So very practically, you
will define your service
as a policy based on templates.
And then based on the
regional mapping on data
locality that you need, you
can choose to use subnetworks.
And based on the needs
for global communication,
you can use global networks.
And then you can
apply policy to those,
and those are security rules,
firewall rules that go over how
those services can communicate.
And on top of that, you have the
organization and the control.
I'm going to spend a
little bit of time going
through a couple of use cases
that I think it reflect some
of this mapping and capabilities
that you might find useful
in a wired network
infrastructure.
From a web-serving, it
is important to serve
close to the user.
So again, data
locality, the service as
close to the user as possible.
You can have the
service replicated
in the different regions.
In the migration scenario,
you can get access
to the cloud scale.
And at the same time, if you
are thinking of expanding,
you'll have access to the
data locations and the regions
that we provide.
You may have an owner
for those services.
That is separate from the
service of, for instance,
the data processing.
And you have a-- I'm going
to break some news here--
global LB, so it is going
to be a single VIP that
is going to be used for
all the traffic, but again,
serving from the
closest location.
And you can have a
data processing that
is, again, a different owner.
And you have the capabilities
of using the permissions
and control to separate
those while allowing
the communication.
I think we've talked about a
lot of the capabilities of load
balancing.
But it's important,
the global scope
single VIP serving globally
without DNS, the scalability
and auto-scaling and the
performance that comes along
with that.
Let's go through
another scenario.
And I want to emphasize
here certain things
in our capabilities, an
example of centralized batch
processing.
So you have localized databases.
And in this case, it's a very
simple inventory scenario
in which you may have
databases in different regions
where you keep your data for all
the inventory of your business.
But then you have another
different organization
that is an audit
service and is going
to perform data
processing, queries,
on what's the status
of the database.
It's a very centralized.
It is a single unit
that it needs to, maybe
for compliance reasons, find
what is the status of those.
And you're going to
have different owners.
So what do you do?
You will need a global network,
because those services will
need to communicate
with each other
and publish the data to a
central location that is going
to do the data processing.
We will need, as
well, some locality.
The databases are located
and spread around the world,
but they are group in
the different regions.
So we will need to
have the granularity
of that segmentation
in the regions.
And you can set
the policies there.
You can assign the CIDR ranges
to map those region segments
into your CIDR.
And then you have a
NetOps administrator
that is going to take the
responsibility of setting that
up for the whole organization.
You're setting the database.
You have an owner
for that database,
and will be responsible of
configuring the service,
administering that service.
You could use
automated templates
like Deployment
Manager, Cloud Launcher,
and you just kind of spin
the services very easy
with a click.
Then you have a centralized,
let's say, in this case,
data prog, [INAUDIBLE],
Hadoop and Spark,
and that's going to be central.
So this is the LB that
is going to be processing
the data for the compliance
of the data and the inventory.
You need to set up firewalls.
The SecOps is going to
set the policies on each
of those services
and subnetworks
and decide how they are going
to communicate with each other.
And then data can be published
through a centralized location.
You could use [INAUDIBLE].
And then just the private
scope communication
is going to allow you to do
that seamlessly without having
to do any type of
additional mechanisms
to privately connect
those regions.
So again, there is
important aspects
here about a private global
communication, the control
of the users that are
going to be setting
the different services, the
segmentation policies that
are going to be applied to the
network, to the subnetwork,
or to the VM level granularly.
And again, everything
that powers our network
is with a high
performance in scaling,
in throughput, and
in low latency.
With that, I really thank
you all for being here.
And I'm going to welcome
Amit Singhal, who's
our tech lead, who's going to be
talking about hybrid scenarios.
[APPLAUSE]
AMIT SINGHAL: Thanks, Ines.
Hello, everyone.
It's my pleasure to be here.
So today I'll talk
about hybrid clouds
and how Google-managed
services really
make it simple and
easy to provision them.
So hybrid cloud is an essential
part of the migration strategy
for any enterprise.
Most enterprises have
invested in some way
in their on-premises
traditional data center
or building their
private clouds,
so they want to leverage
their existing investment
in private cloud or
their data center.
And so they want to continue
to host static core components
there, and extend on-premises
for growth in public cloud,
and host services that
require rapid scaling
into public cloud.
And this also allows them
to do phased migration
into public cloud while
they're evaluating
various components of it.
So now we'll go into some
common scenarios that
use hybrid cloud, and go
in depth into one of them
to show how managed services
like Cloud VPN and Cloud Router
make it really simple to
provision hybrid clouds.
So in this first
scenario, there's
an enterprise who has set
up their private cloud
to host their web services and
they want to keep it that way.
But now they have a need for
analytics and log processing.
And they don't have a
great infrastructure
for that in their
private cloud, so they
decide to use GCP for that.
So they spin off a
managed Hadoop service
into public cloud.
And to feed data
from on-premises
to this managed set of service,
they need a secure connection.
And Cloud VPN service
makes it really
simple to provision that.
Now, I move on to
second scenario.
It's a hypothetical setup
from a e-commerce enterprise.
And they have their
traditional data center,
but they have set up their web
services into GCP, because they
want to leverage auto-scaling.
But in their data center, they
have customer-sensitive payment
information, so they want to
run their payment processing
application from on-premises.
In addition, they also have
their IT corporate on-premises
and also employee
subnets on-premises.
So again, they want a
secure connection to GCP
and they use Cloud VPN for it.
Now, let's go a little more in
depth into Cloud VPN service.
So Cloud VPN, it provides
the IPSec Tunnel.
It supports both IKE
version v1 and v2.
It also supports both
global and regional model.
So currently, I show
here that there's
a VPN connection
only in one region
and it is used
from both regions.
But now customer can
choose to spin off
another VPN in another region.
And using that, they can--
that allows for traffic
to egress and ingress locally.
And Cloud VPN is a
completely managed service.
All you need to give is public
IP on both peers and a shared
secret password, and that's it.
So it supports high
throughput, up to 1.5 gigabit
per second on a single tunnel.
And we also support
horizontal scaling.
So you can start multiple VPN
tunnels from a single region.
Now this sets up a VPN
tunnel, but you also
require routing to be set
up on both ends for traffic
to go over a VPN tunnel.
And one way to do that
is using static routes.
So this is a good option
for networks which are
small and relatively static.
So now we're going
to some scenarios
where networks are
changing dynamically
and they change frequently.
And we'll see how we can use
other managed services to make
it easy to provision.
So in this scenario, I'm showing
that now customer's web service
traffic is increasing
in one of the regions.
So it's scaling up and
subnet size is growing.
Next, IT spins off a
corporate app in GCP.
And then in on-premises, one
of the employee's subnets
is divided into two
for isolation reasons.
So now, with all these
changes happening,
if you don't want to
intervene manually every time
and reconfigure static
routes, what you can do
is start the Cloud Router.
Cloud Router runs BGP protocol
to auto-discover network
changes on either
side of your network.
And you can start
one Cloud Router
in every region you have VPN.
And it's also a completely
managed service.
It peers with BGP
router on-premises.
And it advertises all subnets
of the region to on-premises.
And all you need to do is
select dynamic routing when
you're configuring your VPN.
And for BGP peering, we use
link local IP addresses.
And this also helps in
preventing any conflict
with other private
address peers you have
on either side of your network.
For instance, you configure
a private ASN on GCP.
For on-premises, you
can give your public ASN
or use a private ASN.
And that's all you need to
do to configure Cloud Router.
Now I'll talk about some
of that advanced features
of Cloud Router which allow for
high availability in failure
scenarios.
Cloud Router supports
graceful restart feature.
What that means is
that if you have
BGP service on-premises
goes down for any reason,
Cloud Router will preserve
routes learned from on-premises
for up to three minutes and your
traffic will not be disrupted.
It will still continue
to flow [INAUDIBLE].
It also supports ECMP.
So now if you have multiple
tunnels from a region
and they're all announcing
same BGP routes.
So that will allow to
distribute traffic equally
among all the tunnels.
Another useful feature is to
configure multiple tunnels
in a primary backup mode.
And how it does is
that if BGP [INAUDIBLE]
says announcing same routers
but with different properties,
then based on the value
of these properties,
one tunnel will be
configured primary
and the other can be back up.
And the properties we use is
MED value, AS path length,
AS prepend.
So now if one tunnel goes
down, the other takes over.
And this is really fast,
because the backup tunnel
was already pre-provisioned
and it can just
take over immediately.
So now we have seen that
how Google-managed services,
like Cloud Router and Cloud
VPN, make it really simple
to provision a secure
connection to GCP
with auto-discoverable networks.
Now, to conclude this
talk, I will recap why GCP.
So first and foremost, it's
about network performance.
GCP delivers high
throughput and low latency.
It is highly scalable,
reliable, and always available.
It provides global network
with virtual private networks
that span globally
across all regions.
And last but not the
least, it provides
managed services, like Cloud
VPN, Cloud Router, Cloud DNS,
and many more as
virtualized network
functions for high
scalability and availability.
So with that, I
conclude this talk.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]